ce qui s'est additionné c'est qu'on
avait prévu le spectacle comme
d'habitude et en fait Monsieur Estrosi
chaque année interdit le spectacle en
faisant en fait un arrêté voilà
Géraldine vous comprenez Christian
Estrosi moi je trouve qu'il a le droit
en tant que mère de Nice il a le droit
de décider par rapport à sa ville les
spectacles qu'il a qu'il a envie de
recevoir ou pas après je sais pas si
c'est légal ou illégal de toute façon il
va y avoir une décision de justice je
pense qu'il estime que le spectacle
autorisé
il y a rien de répréhensible par la loi
d'ailleurs j'ai amené des articles d'un
journaliste d'un petit journal mais qui
est très très honnête de was Hebdo je
vais vous le faire circuler qui
d'ailleurs parle en fait dit qu'il y a
absolument rien dans le spectacle qui
est venu voir le spectacle c'est bien
parce que quand on invite en fait
souvent ils viennent pas au contenu donc
c'est pas par rapport au contenu du
spectacle actuel de Dieudonné mais c'est
par rapport à quoi sont passifs je pense
que c'est l'image qu'il a en fait et ça
fait longtemps que les spectacles
le maire de Nice et Monsieur Estrosi dit
que il n'est pas à l'abri que dans ce
spectacle comme il n'a pas le verbatim
du spectacle il y ait des dérapages à
caractère notamment antisémite et donc
dans le doute il préfère c'est ça en
gros c'est si j'ai bien oui mais alors à
ce moment-là vous condamnez un homme
éternellement et ça fait plusieurs
spectacles il n'y a absolument rien dans
les spectacles moi je ne travaillerai
pas quelqu'un qui dit des choses je vous
le dis tout de suite donc il a rien dans
ce spectacle j'ai amené ça d'ailleurs
on a beaucoup de mères aussi qui ne
l'interdisent absolument jamais là il le
fait la plupart d'ailleurs parce qu'on
tourne trois quatre fois par semaine
depuis le mois de janvier et moi je
m'occupe de la tournée c'est moi qui
trouve les salles et donc en fait
il n'y a absolument on a eu deux mers en
fait le maire de Compiègne qui fait ça
chaque année j'ai pu parler au directeur
du cabinet d'ailleurs du maire de
Compiègne
qui on a demandé s'il pouvait rencontrer
le maire de Compiègne et le maire de
Compiègne en fait le coup de dire du
cabinet m'a dit écoutez en fait entre
nous on a regardé des sketchs on a
beaucoup ri vous voyez donc c'est c'est
en fait on invite ces gens-là à venir
avec grand plaisir en essayant de
nouveau d'aller à Nice vous saviez très
bien qu'il y aura un arrêté municipal
donc vous avez fait ça pour que le
spectacle qui rencontre un succès
modérés etc
non mais c'est de la provocation d'aller
à Nice maintenant
c'est pas de la provocation parce qu'on
l'invite et justement on n'a pas fait de
à ce moment-là on n'a pas répondu on n'a
pas essayé en fait de d'habitude on
saisit le tribu administratif d'ailleurs
on a gagné contre le maire de Compiègne
qui a dû nous payer 2000 euros mais
parce qu'on n'a pas fait justement parce
que Dieudonné dans une démarche de paix
et dans une démarche sincère de vouloir
apaiser les choses
entre les deux ou Dieudonné avait
insulté Estrosi et il avait perdu
d'ailleurs il avait dû payer des
dommages intérêts il me semble non alors
écoutez ça possible moi je m'occupe de
la tournée plus le mois de janvier et je
vous affirme qu'on a aucun problème sur
trois cas dates par semaine en fait qui
sont vraiment on fait trois quatre dates
par semaine vous imaginez bien c'est que
tous les maires nous interdisaient on
pourrait pas jouer quoi et il y a
beaucoup de niçois qui veulent venir le
voir et il y a beaucoup de gens en fait
du bassin de l'histoire alors je vais
dire l'arrêter de Christian Estrosi
annoncé faire de même pour la conférence
de Tariq Ramadan qui devait donner une
conférence à Nice dimanche prochain Nice
Matin affirmer que la réalité n'était
pas encore pris à cet instant puisqu'il
ne connaissait pas l'adresse du
spectacle notre vie n'est pas une ville
qui peut accepter à la fois ceux qui ont
à répondre de violences faites aux
femmes de xénophobie d'antisémitisme et
de racisme ce sont des sujets ornissent
que je n'ai jamais toléré et que je ne
tolérer
c'est très bien franchement c'est c'est
le pouvoir du maire on dit souvent les
politiques n'agissent pas lui c'est le
pouvoir du maire d'interdire alors
ensuite il peut y avoir des recours
devant les tribunaux il faut voir ce que
le préfet va dire mais moi madame je
considère que ce spectacle là c'est de
la pure provocation il y a des risques
de troubles à l'ordre public pas du tout
ce qui se joue c'est annulation ou non
il n'y a jamais eu de risque à troubles
publics depuis des années dans les
spectacles de Dieudonné parce qu'ils
sont interdits par là
absolument pas il remplit toutes les
salles excusez-moi on a rempli la salle
il y a pas trop belle en public ça c'est
faux comme l'autre fois j'avais monsieur
Delormeau je suis désolé mais je lui
parle il n'est pas là mais je suis ravie
que tout le monde soit là au contraire
monsieur Delormeau qui disait tous ces
spectateurs étaient antisémites dans les
spectacles au théâtre de la Main d'or
mais c'est absolument faux monsieur moi
je suis
des trucs
les autres spectacles
pardon moi depuis que je travaille avec
lui je n'ai jamais vu de gens déplacer
Tor antisémite dans ces spectacles
pour moi les Juifs c'est une secte une
escroquerie ça date de quand madame
en fait il a comparé aussi la Shoah de
la pornographie mémorielle il a dit que
les plus gros escrocs de la planète
étaient les Juifs
qu'il avait dépassé les limites je pense
qu'il l'a dit clairement voilà
maintenant
c'est un monsieur je crois le connaître
maintenant pouvoir beaucoup parler à
value avant de travailler avec lui et je
crois vraiment honnêtement vous êtes un
type gentil de fond et qui n'a jamais
moi il m'a jamais dit de choses déplacer
voilà alors on va regarder la réponse
de presse mais citez-moi ces derniers
spectacles parce qu'on parle beaucoup
dans le bassin niçois bah l'idée c'est
ça résume si vous voulez si on commence
à mettre des petites communes parfois
c'est un peu compliqué mais c'était en
termes de communication il faut il faut
simplement que Monsieur Estrosi nous
dise ce qui le dérange ben non si c'est
ce qui le dérange c'est que ma personne
soit sur sa commune bon le tout c'est
que ça se passe bien voilà c'est
je pense que c'est un acte politique de
m'interdire et de le dire et de le faire
dire bon il faut que maintenant l'acte
politique ça soit un acte de
réconciliation voilà et on peut le faire
ensemble avec Monsieur Estrosi je lui
tends la main alors oui le problème
c'est qu'il est allé assez loin quand
même Dieudonné c'est ça le souci c'est à
dire que il présente ses excuses alors
avec toute la sincérité du monde vous le
dites il est sincère il est dans une ça
fait longtemps qu'il m'en parle mais
très bien pour autant que tout le monde
est prêt à la recevoir ça et tout le
monde est prêt à le croire et à le
pardonner et attendre une marque donc
bah moi je pense qu'on doit attendre la
main à quelqu'un qui l'a d'ailleurs
c'est je pense la religion juive mais
quand même pour le pardon
toutes les phrases que peut citer
Géraldine un moment donné il les a pensé
il les a dit il les a assumés vous savez
madame moi je vais vous dire autre chose
c'est qu'il y a plein de moments au
moins je pardon je vous ai entendu
il y a il y a aussi des gens qui moi
devant moi l'ont traité de gorille de
singes et de [__] et que c'était un con
et ça personne n'en parle jamais eu ça
plein de fois devant moi c'est époux en
table des gens qui l'a invité à manger
des spectacles publics mais combien de
spectacles vous avez vu je vous pose une
question sincère je suis quelqu'un de
vouloir chercher le cœur j'adorais
combien de spectacles qui pète un câble
j'adorais Dieudonné est-ce que vous avez
vu son spectacle en paix mais en 2014
quels sont les trois derniers spectacles
que vous avez vu j'ai le sont les
derniers sketchs personne ne le sait
tout le monde en parle j'ai vu des
personnes non pardon personne ne voit
ces derniers spectacle qui a du génie
c'est important qui est brillant c'est
un type qui écrit très bien c'est parti
ça n'empêche pas qu'Estrosi donc ça a
pas je ne veux pas d'un type qui a été
accusé de violence conjugales je ne peux
pas d'intime qui a été accusé
d'antisémite je ne veux pas de ce mec là
ils ont il a tous les droits
ça me semble logique non mais Jean-Marie
après
malheureusement marqué à vie comme un
tatouage sur le front tu vois si tu as
une croix gammée sur le front tu peux
plus l'effacer et après tu peux devenir
le plus gentil mec de l'univers et je
pense la vérité actuelle par exemple de
Dieudonné mais c'est très très dur c'est
impossible Jésus dans la Bible dit le
voleur il regrette d'avoir volé il est
violeurs et dis-tu je te crois tu ne
seras plus jamais valeur mais pour tout
le monde non ça c'est pas mal
parce que chez toi tu seras toujours en
voleur c'est exactement ce qui se ment
pas mais vous dites qu'il a changé un
moment donné il a été condamné à 10000
euros d'amende un jurassiste envers
Rachel kan le 30 septembre 2022 moi je
vous parle
il avait
ce qu'on dit d'un mot c'était 1 % du
spectacle tout le reste il a critiqué la
corruption
il a tapé sur tout le monde tout le
temps et ça fait plusieurs spectacles ça
fait longtemps qu'il n'y a rien elle
entend 37 ans 2022
alors je suis avocate c'est vrai que il
a été condamné il a payé juridiquement
sa dette à la société mais néanmoins
pour moi c'est inacceptable les propos
que Géraldine vient de citer moi je suis
juive je trouve que c'est inacceptable
et je ne crois pas moi je suis pas juive
et je trouve que c'est une action
est-ce que vous trouvez une acceptable
aussi quand on doute sur la sincérité de
ces excuses je vais vous dire moi j'ai
un énorme doute je pense que c'est un
coup de com et
écoutez je vous dis ce que je pense
alors justement
on a les photos il était avec Francis
Lalanne Auschwitz sur les comptes
alors quoi qu'il fasse ça ne va jamais
madame se prendre comme ça Auschwitz je
trouve ça non c'est Francis Lalanne qui
lui a demandé d'y aller et elle a
accepté d'y aller non non non
irrespectueux non c'est Israël magazine
qui a publié ça Dieudonné justement on
me dit on en parle pas c'est pas lui qui
s'est passé
absolument il a voulu publier oui il m'a
dit je garde ça pour moi c'est intime
justement il a voulu faire ça ici mais
attendez madame c'est Israël magazine
qui l'a publié Dieudonné n'en a
absolument pas parlé il a pas publié sur
son site etc et d'ailleurs non mais je
vous le dis c'est il a il a en fait il a
il a fait ça d'une manière intime pour
lui-même pour justement trouver
justement à lui-même c'est une histoire
entre lui et lui-même
qui le garde pour lui dire à Monsieur
André Darmon d'Israël magazine mais
qu'il le garde pour lui qu'il le garde
pour lui il veut absolument se faire
pardonner s'il veut la réponse
ça ne va jamais en fait une tournée de
la salle problème c'est l'inverse qu'on
peut douter de la sincérité
quand on en a parlé ici je pensais que
ces excuses pouvaient être sincères je
lui ai donné
et je vous en remercie je vous en
remercie mais là ça me gêne beaucoup
l'entreprise de communication quand on
va ensuite
communications
la moindre des dignités c'est de pas
prendre de photos qu'elle soit ni de soi
ni du site ni de rien
d'Israël magazine
pour vous on va revenir sur la
description
interdit Dieudonné de jouer à Nice pour
vous c'est inadmissible pour moi un élu
doit quand même un moment donné ne pas
répéter tout ce qui se dit ne doit pas
condamné quelqu'un éternel allemand à un
moment donné un élu doit venir voir par
lui-même le spectacle ont d'ailleurs
vous êtes tous invité vous-même à venir
voir le spectacle chez à vous le dire
c'est moi vraiment qui vous le demande
avec l'amitié pour venir voir le
spectacle vous êtes invités
je vous signale aussi que le bal des
tonnelles il a il n'appelle pas ça le
bal des quenelles il a décidé d'appeler
ça le bal de la réconciliation il va
inviter tous les gens qui en fait lui en
vol pour pouvoir parler avec lui et
justement pour pouvoir montrer le
spectacle et vous êtes tous invité à
grand plaisir je peux pas faire mieux
que ça moi j'essaye de prendre c'est
pourquoi
4 dates par semaine depuis le mois de
janvier pourquoi plus de 60 70 date 80
date des gens acceptent des maires
acceptent ils se passent rien appare
comme tout le monde moi ce qu'il a dit
c'est condamnable et ce qui se disait au
théâtre de l'amador mais il a dit
lui-même je passe à autre chose moi je
me dis que je vais passer à autre chose
parce que moi il m'a beaucoup fait rire
dans les années 90 il m'a beaucoup fait
rire donc je vais passer à autre chose
d'accord je me dis j'essaie de
comprendre et l'argument c'est Christian
Estrosi le maire de Nice ne veut pas de
lui parce qu'il a été condamné donc ça
veut dire qu'il tous les gens qui ont
été condamnés ils rentrent plus à Nice
il ne parle plus à personne de condamner
son argument pour moi il tient pas qui
disent autre chose qui disent par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit avant je ne
veux pas entendre parler de Dieudonnée
il rentrera pas dans ma ville ça peut
aller non c'est pas tous les gens
condamnés
n'a pas réussi à donner une
représentation à Nice parce que j'ai
toujours veillé à ce que nous le pistons
pour ne pas lui permettre de le faire et
une fois de plus et bien
naturellement j'ai pris un arrêté pour
interdire cette représentation et nous
mobiliserons tout ce que nous pouvons
pour l'empêcher de faire cette
représentation excusez-moi je peux me
permettre de nous le donc je trouve ça
alors là pour le coup inadmissible on
n'est pas en train de pister un animal
et il a toujours utilisé ces termes-là
voilà je le dis alors maintenant moi je
suis pour la paix on l'invite mais
c'était avant nous le tracons ou le
piston et cetera et ça moi ça me choque
profondément il devrait venir voir le
spectacle si c'est un homme intelligent
je le pense c'est ce que je pense aussi
il fait un peu comme un défi ça fait 15
ans qui rentre pas à Nice donc il ne
rentrera jamais à Nice moi j'aimerais
bien que Christian Estrosi avec de la
police on va voir un spectacle de
données avec des policiers avec les gens
qui connaissent les mots qui sont
répréhensibles ils sont condamnables on
va voir si il se passe quelque chose
tout de suite on arrête le spectacle la
police ça dégage s'il se passe rien et
que les gens nissent sont contents de
venir voir Dieudonné qui a 1500
personnes qui sont venues applaudir
Dieudonné et qui a pas un dégât à un
moment donné moi ce qui est étonnant
c'est quand qu'on dit pardon pourquoi
pourquoi il arrive à faire 80 dates
c'est qu'il y a une demande
s'il fait du succès moi ce qui me
dérange c'est que monsieur je vais vous
dire les gens sont de tout bloquer et de
toute personnalité c'est étonnant et
justement tous les gens se parlent moi
j'ai des gens qui étaient contre Dieudo
qui sont venus le voir ils m'ont dit on
veut voir par nous-mêmes et ils sont
sidérés c'est qui se rendent compte
qu'il y a pas de haine qui a pas de
troubles en public il y a rien de tout
ça voilà mais c'est drôle son spectacle
est drôle ça c'est autre chose
si c'était un spectacle humoristique ou
c'était je pense que Jean-Marie l'autre
jour m'avait dit que c'était un des plus
gros d'ailleurs juste pour finir deux
secondes Cyril il y a des gens
comme il a été super loin qui s'est mis
super dans la merde et que il a été
blacklisté par tout le monde maintenant
faut dire pardon parce qu'il faut manger
faut faire de l'oseille donc je dis
pardon je fais un spectacle lisse et
j'essaye de me réconcilier
parce que les gens ne savent pas il a
été élevé dans une école jésuite et
c'est un type qui est beaucoup plus
humaniste que vous ne le pensez
qu'il est dérapé comme dit ça
moi
il a dérapé pendant des années donc
aujourd'hui je me dis pendant des années
de répondre en justice est-ce que si
vous on vous avez interdit monsieur on
avait dit depuis des années des choses
et on vous a jamais tendu le micro
est-ce que quelque part vous auriez pas
dérapé des fois je vois que vous énervez
c'est ce que vous n'aurez la société
qu'il est allé aussi loin non
j'essaie toujours de comprendre l'humain
non mais c'est pour ça que je suis ravi
de vous avoir tous parce que je pense
qu'on est tous des humains et qu'on a
tous les
cas plus moi je le pense changer je vous
ai vu l'autre jour dire que vous étiez
prêt à l'excuser quand j'ai vu monsieur
Hanouna moi ça m'a touché parce que je
trouve la seule chose qui nous lie c'est
cette capacité en fait de se parler
après on n'est pas d'accord ou pas
quelqu'un vous pourrez lui dire tout ce
que vous voulez on peut beaucoup lui
parler en fait moi il m'a toujours ne
pas me dire ce que je veux des fois moi
je lui ai dit des choses moi des fois
j'ai engueulé tout il s'est un type on
peut lui dire voilà une intelligence
aussi des choses à l'épreuve du temps et
à l'épreuve des faits parce que là il
vient de demander pardon donc pourquoi
pas
vous pouvez aussi quand quelqu'un
demande pardon on n'est pas obligé de
nous d'accepter cette demande de pardon
immédiatement de prendre du temps non
mais ça il était pas contre ça il l'a
dit mais je pense qu'il faut quand même
aller voir un de ces spectacles
franchement
qui est pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous non moi je pense que c'est ça sert
à rien de l'interdire puisque de toute
façon il y aura des scènes où il fera
son spectacle il y aura des gens qui on
le voit et ce spectacle apparemment
alors je sais pas c'est le même qu'avec
Francis Lalanne c'est c'est
indifférentiel est le nouveau il y a une
date je crois en septembre au zénith ça
a créé une énorme polémique il a été
visionné par le Zénith apparemment il y
a pas de trouble à la République et il
n'est pas choquant donc je pense qu'il
faut une chance de le dire c'est très
décevant peut-être mais il n'y en a
jamais eu
c'est pas le Zénith qui va décider le
zénithme interdire c'est le préfet qui
est en train d'étudier l'interdiction
éventuelle pour risque de parler au
public du spectacle il n'y a jamais eu
de problème
il parle de pardon
tout un tas de choses comme ça
je voudrais que vous veniez vraiment
vous demande vous pensez
du spectacle il va décider même d'accord
il a dû donner un texte pour le pour le
pour le Zénith on a dû soumettre un
texte moi profondément bon je trouve ça
donc il y a plus de quenelles en tous
les cas il y a le bal des Hal de la
réconciliation où il vous invite tous
voilà avec vraiment et moi je le
souhaite aussi du fond du cœur vous
puissiez venir vous par vous-même voir
le spectacle et parler avec lui
peut-être lui dire ce que vous pensez il
y a aucun problème j'aimerais qu'on voit
ce qu'on peut citer les spectateurs s'il
vous plaît oui à 28 % regardez non à
71%. mettez vos pancartes
derrière s'il vous plaît merci non à 71%
c'est voilà oui c'est bon ici c'est je
savais pas qu'il y a autant de nom